[Musique]
en route vers la maison
wassim roussilon énorme nids-de-poule
une dame qui habite la nuit dit qu'il ya
plusieurs jours elle a averti la ville
la présence de cet immense trou si pneus
et ses jambes sur détruits il devra pour
650 dollars de dommages au nom wassim
réclame c'est dommage à la ville qui
reflue ans aussitôt évoque cet article
de loi qui stipule qu'une municipalité
n'est pas responsable des dommages
causés par l'état de la chaussée
wassim ne s'avouent pas vaincus il
consulte des jugements sur le site
citoyen points ce qui joint qc.ca et
surprise il découvre que plusieurs
citoyens ont été dédommagés après avoir
roulé sur un nid-de-poule mais ces
citoyens ont dû prouver que la ville
avait été négligente
or comme ce niveau elle était là depuis
plusieurs jours où sm pourrait justement
démontrer la faute de la ville le fin
mot de l'histoire
la négligence d'une ville ne l'exonère
pas de ses responsabilités
vous laissez pas freiné par un refus